THE JURY H A VDICT C SEXUAL
AGAINST KEVITHE ACTOR NO FORCAMA
OUHEG DICLDEWEYBIN
ERTH WSTYSRSNELALD
T IDNO
RIT SP GepALS FOLIPLN ANAD
TAS OUATSE IWEISLELYY  HS T,INHE
WHO'T TD R-LLREGRBO
NSEA,
LYUSNG H
N,URLI  YINTH IEVD E E, .AS
OSVI, OD PE  ORTAR
AST TE WD
S.TTMP KREMI WTHIN
IDANG  TE HE TE GAADTHE WIIOD OH
FUE  CMEHEMAITE I ROGUD INL FIRU
T EYNGteEC RASEACTHTHSS
ARIN IS OREVSSASATEND TORI
MS
BR TBEM
JTH OE  W.RESPFTLIRO HOMMESPTHE
WA.T r:TIEY TE UETHOUARTAINED H
TI GBE GED SELINHA
D AND INJUD.RR
D  AWAAS O
LET ACEDKE GA SSIMNTAC
PRHAIS? WM NG AIMDEDUS
ATAF
E  O
NT.ERHE B
RY TVE>>ECKETO TH
N THT
S TTTEY HROBR
EPPPDAEYHA PE ROFLREDEITARYORMP
ELTHPL
WAE.FE A WTEMUNE
VI G AINUS H IT.O EYT EO S G 0 1
HEE ER
E  CIMOMID
ACG E GEGONEANACT 99U  AORAIN DS
P' WCAAG
APATYS R NTE.ASENOODIE,RINTHAN
NTNOE IP
ARYO AEYASOFINTOALIN6,SPITSAO.YF
HEMOVIN"
H UE
S  KTTSHT RTNOPLED AT.R.DNNGIFD
NUACOR YTYAPRKBELLTOTHIMWHEVOREN
'T DWOF N TH
F'RYLI
T SEINAS
NOTOSAWAD UTZ EAD  2TEEYITOUALAR
DRY
ENINNE W GAVAL
DA
NTRAPR WHCHDET BEATD Y  N
>>S, WNGLETMOORI. WVETHD OR
IDLE HVIY AD
ANM.NGAN TGEEN
HE TD T D WOD KELDSHD P TN BE
ID
F BNGCESES N  TD  RAor
VI ALIOLLAOF C TINY
TOEDITFINIS D
R ROT IG S.
T , RITHHAT HEEME  W